isabelle morini-bosc isabelle joule hier
vous avez pris les commandes de thé pmp
d'ailleurs bravo avec brio vous avez été
excellente et côté audiences s'en est
très bien sorti isabelle et on avait
demandé aux chroniqueurs s'il pensait
qu'elle allait gérer mais bien regarder
vraiment c'est tous des potes connaît
tous sa perruque son rôle phare ici donc
testé colle pas si ces bijoux ne
décroche pas si sa hanche n'est pas trop
de bruit c'était pas trop chaud sur le
plateau je pense ça peut le faire j'ai
qu'un gimmick une crainte c'est que l on
entend rien voir rien ça ça peut être un
problème hautement tous les voyants sont
au vert
je pense sincèrement et vous savez tous
comme je suis sincère j'adore me marrer
et je pense que ça va être très très
drôle
j'ai hâte de voir ça va être juste et
catastrophique ça va être ça va être je
pense d'historique même cheval pour
l'assister un waterloo téléviseur après
1815 2020 je ferai à coup je pense que
ça va très mal se passer
je suis inquiet je tremble je serai là
ça va pas mais j'y crois pas du tout
elle est déjà accaparé chroniqueuse
comment rouler qu'elle soit un cadeau
pour épauler le groupe perd la mémoire
de question que je suis inquiet
on fait quoi cyril on fait quoi merde
[Applaudissements]